Nigeria Africa's most populous nation is
going to the polls on March 28 current
President Goodluck Jonathan has support
mainly in the Christian South but he's
said to be strongly challenged by
retired General Muhammadu Buhari whose
support comes from the predominantly
Muslim north
Nigeria's population is pretty evenly
split between Christians and Muslims and
for decades there was a partial
agreement that saw the presidency rotate
between north and south that agreement
ended when president jonathan came to
power in 2011 leaving some in the north
feeling disenfranchised this election is
expected to be the most closely
contested since the end of military rule
in 1999